we are here with the incomparable marie
osmond
and i happen to be with your brother and
it's funny because we talked about some
deep stuff
and really he's not that deep
well that's going to lead perfectly into
our game donnie versus marie and
we asked him some questions
um and uh now we're going to ask you in
a game we're calling donny versus marie
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
okay here's how it works i'm going to
ask you a question and after you answer
we'll see what donnie said
and if you can match three out of five
of donnie's answers you win and if you
win
donny said he'll go on his instagram and
sing paper roses your iconic hit song
but if you lose
apparently you have agreed to go on your
instagram and saying puppy love his
iconic song
okay
this is making it
in other words i have to win okay gotcha
okay
okay
here we go
number one who is more likely to forget
the lyrics to a song
me
here's what donnie said
so marie's gonna say it's me
but it's marie
okay
oh no
who doesn't mind re-wearing costumes
without being cleaned
he would probably say me all right
johnny's answer was
that's definitely me
yeah it's him
he's right it is him okay well that's
but i got that one wrong okay all right
we're one for one here all right who is
likely to eat food after it fell on the
floor
donnie
and donny's response was
oh that's definitely marie
she will just
she has the three second rule
actually she pushes it to 10 seconds
i thought this is where we could bond
because i am the same rule i mean he's
kind of weird yeah that's okay i'll give
him that one okay
um who was the favorite growing up
johnny
uh and donnie's response was
me
marie's gonna say it's her but it was me
all right you get that one
we're two to two
okay i'm just going by what i'm just
going by what i know his brain would say
it was me
all right well this is the tiebreaker
who is more likely to keep a secret
well it's me but he'll say it's him
well here's what donnie said
me
because
i told her i was the peacock on the mass
singing she's still full of crap and she
let it out
[Laughter]
[Music]
is that true did you tell people he was
the math singer
so he told me because he was flying in
and out and then i was doing some press
i can't remember what project i was
doing
and uh and their network people they
said oh yeah how about that you know
donnie's the pizza they set me up and i
went oh i guess they told him because
it's the network and i said oh yeah
right and then i realized it set me up
and i said and then i tried to get out
of it and oh he was so mad oh my gosh he
was so mad
i loved that that was the answer we all
jump for joy when donnie was doing that
what does this mean this means he's
singing paper roses right
it means he is singing paper roses marie
i'm watching all right three words
my response on my social
means you win
marie's newest album unexpected is out
now and also her latest special and
evening with marie on byu tv
is out please enjoy it thank you so much
marie thank you
[Music]